is it true all the White Walkers White
Walkers have been gone for thousands of
years so he was like
and that man sees what he sees
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season 8
outline video I wanted to share
something with you today that I am sure
some of you will love and some of you
will hate apparently someone on reddit
made his own outline for how he thinks
season 8 will play out and his outline
has become very popular in fact it has
pretty much gone viral at this point
everyone has been talking about this the
past couple of days and even Time
magazine has written an article about
this outline so I figured I would read
it here then see what all of you have to
say about this the person who posted
this on reddit goes by the username the
triple B in case you would like to read
it for yourself I will put the link down
in the description of the video but I
will read what he wrote word for word
then I will give you a few of my own
thoughts at the end of the video shall
we begin
Jamie will convince at least a
contingent if not the entire Lannister
army to join him and going north
they'll combined armies go north and
fight the army of the Dead defeating it
but at great cost
however the knight King in his Dragon
are not there but why they flew south
and destroy King's Landing Trading his
army of a hundred thousand for the 1
million in King's Landing including
Cersei they foreshadowed it too much in
the finale
[Music]
how many people live here million give
or take small people than the entire
North crammed into that I would anyone
want to live that way there's more work
in the city brothels are far superior
you're on in the golden company arrived
at King's Landing to a trap where they
are also killed and joined the knight
king's army
Daenerys finds out that she is pregnant
bran and Sam keep John's parentage is
secret after Danny and John declare they
are getting married or they at least
tell John who doesn't have a chance to
tell Danny before the end Jaime ends up
at the end killing Cersei to fulfill the
prophecy in the last battle he survives
to become the 1,000th Lord Commander and
restore the wall and honor to the Nights
Watch bran survives and get the twins
when it's all over as Tyrion is good to
his word to double what he is being paid
The Hound survives and stays with Tyrion
who retires as hand of the Queen and
goes back to Casterly Rock as its Lord
he changes the Lannisters wealth from
gold to wine as he opens his vineyard
there and becomes richer by supplying
the Seven Kingdoms remember there's
always a Clegane to help a Lannister so
the Hound goes with him am I gonna die
in this [ __ ] City you might this is all
your idea seems every bad idea some
bonus to come behind it and some again
come to help them see it through
cleganebowl never happens because they
hate us Gendry survives and is
legitimized by John and or Dany
bittersweet ending is that Dany gives
birth to a child maybe even twins but
dies in childbirth or shortly after John
becomes king of the Seven Kingdoms but
loses another love of his life and
raises his child or children alone in
the battles all the dragons die however
in some last scene it's discovered that
they laid eggs before they died Sam is
writing the story in the last scene is
him putting the book away after telling
the story to someone maybe his grandkids
and he'll be played by George RR
and john declares there's no more
bastards foreshadowed by the
conversation with Melisandre and Davos
on Dragonstone he's a good lad a poor
land from flea bottom who happens to be
your nephew
what is the life of one bastard boy
against a kingdom
everything
the boy was died Gendry helps reforged
Valyrian steel or works on dragon glass
into weapons to help win the war he is
legitimized by Danny and or John and
ends up getting storms end Arya is going
to use that Valyrian steel dagger to
save someone important from a white
Walker perhaps Sansa or Gendry Jorah
Mormont is either going to die or die
sweet Robin somehow becomes a great
fighter
sweet Robyn somehow becomes a great
fighter my son says thoughts in their
eyes all the time they could walk this
one like a girl with palsy the Citadel
was overrun by White Walkers and Salmons
up being the grand maester after it's
all over the oath of not taking a wife
or kids has done away with by John for
Kingsguard the Citadel and whoever else
the White Walkers were defeated and came
back before the wall needs to be rebuilt
and manned again just in case this would
be the great deed Jamie does and
restores him to honor after he
dispatches Cersei joining the Nights
Watch should not be a lifetime
commitment it should be like a tour of
duty where you only serve for a certain
amount of time more people would sign up
knowing it wasn't for life but they
could still get some glory all righty
then
first I just have to say there are
several things here that I do agree with
but there are also several things here
that I disagree with I do agree with
what he said about Jaime
he is definitely heading north to
Winterfell and he may even try and
gather up as many troops as he can I
also believe Gendry will be legitimized
by John or Daenerys in the end and it
also makes sense that Arya would kill at
least one white Walker what the Valyrian
steel dagger she has but I disagree with
a lot of the stuff he said about the
night king and his army I do not think
they will make it to the Citadel I can
see them being stopped away before that
I don't see the night king raising all
of King's Landing either if the night
King turned a million people into whites
I don't see how any of them would
survive an attack from a force of that
size there was something he did mention
that I had never heard before and I
think it's a great idea the Nights Watch
should not be a lifelong commitment it
should be turned into a service like the
military where you can sign up for a
certain amount of time maybe two to four
years of service that would certainly
help with their numbers if people knew
they could eventually retire or reenlist
if they chose to do so they could still
send their criminals there too but maybe
make some new standards don't send all
of the murderers and rapists there clean
it up and make it a little more
respectable
perhaps people would take honor and
serving at the wall again they would
have to iron out all the details and
make sure people were signing up before
they could turn anyone away but I do
think it could work
overall what up to say this outline
pretty much sounded like a collection of
all the popular theories that are
already out there I'm not exactly sure
how old this post is but hey if everyone
is coming to these conclusions then
maybe it's what is going to happen so we
shall see but let me know what you think
about this outline considering it went
viral some of you may have already seen
this either way it's open for discussion
and hopefully I will see some of you
down in the comment section also don't
forget I put the link to the original
post down in the description of the
video in case you wanted to read it for
yourself I want to thank everyone for
stopping by to check out the video I
really appreciate that as always and I
also want to thank all of my supporters
on patreon have a great day everyone
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]